はい、それではですね、こちら基本操作、ここではですね、n8nの基本操作を覚えながら、AIエージェントの基本的な仕組みを理解し、ご自身のアイデアを形にするための考え方を身につけていきましょう。
それではまずはじめに行うこととしましては、n8nのアカウントの作成というのが必要となりますので、ご自身お手元のPCの方でですね、n8nと検索をかけていただいて、ホームページを開くと、今画面に出ているのがn8n公式のホームページとなります。
今回はですね、アカウントの作成に進めていきますので、画面右上、このゲットスタートと書いてあるオレンジのボタンをクリックしてください。
そうしますと、このような画面に映りますので、必要なお名前であったりですとか、メールアドレス、またですね、パスワード等の設定をしていただいて、スタートフリー。
この青いボタンを押していただければと思います。
n8nはですね、14日間無料で使えるトライアル期間というのも設けておりますので、ぜひご活用いただければと思います。
実際にアカウントが作成できましたら、このような画面に映るかと思います。
こちらはダッシュボード、いわゆる管理画面と言われる画面となりまして、非常に今後 n8n を活用していく上では、この画面というのが重要な機能を備えている画面となりますので、
まずはこちらの画面について、主要な機能をご紹介させていただければと思います。
それではまずはですね、こちら画面の左上、こちらですね。こちらワークフローと記載があるところなんですが、こちらはですね、実際に皆さんが今後作成していく自動化の仕組み、いわゆるワークフローと言われるようなものが一覧で表示されるものになっています。
こちらからですね、今作っているワークフロー、過去作ったワークフローというのが一元で管理できる画面となりますので、このワークフロー画面ですね、皆さんもぜひ覚えていただいておいてください。
はい、それではですね、続いて右側、Credentialと書いてあるところ、こちらを押してみます。
こちらは何かと言いますと、数々の外部サービスと連携する際にですね、認証情報というのが必要になるんですね。
画面にもですね、Googleスプレッドシート、Googleカレンダーであったり、Gmail、あるいはですね、スラックだったりとか、オープンAI、チャットGPTですね。
こういったサービスとの連携をする際には、認証情報と言われるような、連携をするための認証ですね、これが必要になっておりますので、実際にこのワークショップの方でも、こちらのクレデンシャルの設定等が後々出てきますので、その際にですね、改めてお伝えさせていただければなというふうに思います。
それでは続いて、このエクスキュージョンというところなんですが、こちらですね、ご自身が作成したワークフローがいつ、どのように動いたのか、その履歴、いわゆるログというものですね、が一覧で記録される画面になります。
現在画面上ですと赤くエラーとなっていた部分であったり、緑色でサクセスとなっていたりだとか、様々な表示があるかと思うんですけども、
こちらは実際にですね、作成したワークフローがちゃんと実行できたかどうか、またエラーというのは実行できず、途中で止まってしまったと、エラーが発生してしまったというふうな画面表示となりますので、
こういったところもですね、実際に今後きちんと動いているか、またエラーが起きたら、どこで、いつ、どんなエラーが起きたか、こういったのを確認する非常に重要な機能となりますので、こちらも皆さんもぜひ覚えておいてください。
それでは最後、このデータテーブルと書いてある部分なんですが、現状はですね、ベータ版となっておりまして、本格実装はまだされてはいないんですけども、
こちらは、n8nのクラウド上にデータを保存できるExcel、またはスプレッドシートのようなものだとイメージいただければと思います。
本来であれば、外部のデータベースと連携をする必要というのが基本的にはある。
例えば、ご自身のスプレッドシートとの連携であったり、ご自身のExcelとの連携、これが基本的には必要にはなるんですけども、
簡単なデータであれば、このn8nの中でデータ管理というのが保存管理できるようになりましたと。そういったのがこのデータテーブルズという機能ですので、今後、現状はベータ版ですが、今後本格実装された際には、ぜひご活用いただけると良いかなというふうに思います。
ワークフロー、クレデンシャル、エクスキュージョン、データテーブルズとご説明させていただきましたが、もう一点ですね、大事な機能というのがございまして、画面左側のメニュー欄のですね、こちらテンプレートと書いてあるところ、こちらをちょっと開いてみたいと思います。
そうしますと、こういった画面に映るのですが、こちらはですね、世界中の n8n ユーザーが作成したワークフローのテンプレートが一覧できるページとなっています。
現在はですね、6700ちょっと、日々増え続けているんですけども、非常に多くのテンプレートというのがこちらに記載がありますので、
今後、ご自身でワークフローを作成する際には、既存のテンプレートから少しアイデアを持ってきたり、自分と作りたいものと近いものがあるかな、と参考にしていただけると良いかなと思います。
このように実際のワークフロー画面と、ワークフローの説明等がこのように記載がありますので、
ぜひこちらのテンプレートも今後活用していきますので、皆さんもぜひこちらのテンプレートも一緒に覚えておいていただけたらなというふうに思います。
それでは管理画面ダッシュボードの簡単なご説明は以上とさせていただきまして、続いて最初のワークフローを実際に作ってみたいと思います。
それでは、まずワークフローを作る上では、この右上、Create Workflow というボタンを押していただいて、ここから作成を進めていきます。
そうしますと、このような画面が映ったかと思います。こちらはキャンバス画面と言われる画面になっておりまして、この画面上で実際のワークフローを作成していく、こういった画面になります。
まずはですね、こちらのキャンバス画面における基本的な機能のご紹介をさせていただければと思います。
まずはですね、左上、My Workflowと、My Workflow 92、92と今数字が入っていますが、こちらを押していただくと、いろいろ任意で変更することができるんですね。
こちらはご自身が作成するワークフローの名前タイトルというのを決めることができます。 今回はデモという名前に変更していこうと思いますので、デモという風に変更をかけて
ok という形ですね。 続いてこちら右上でセーブと記載があるこのオレンジのボタンなんですけども、こちら非常に
非常に重要な機能となっておりまして、n8nというのはですね、実際その変更だったり編集が起こった際の自動保存機能というのがないサービスになるんですね。
Excelだったりとかスプレッドシート、これらは自動保存機能があるサービスになるんですけども、このn8nは自動保存機能がないので、一度変更を加えた際には、
このセーブのボタンを押して、ボタンを押していただくこと、これをちょっと伏せ付けていただけると良いかなと思いますので、はい、こちらを押さえておいていただければと思います。
はい、それで、以上、キャンバス画面における基本的なご説明をお伝えさせていただきましたが、はい、実際にこのワークフローじゃない、このワークショップを進めていくにあたって、
その他の機能もご紹介させていただきますので、ぜひ皆様楽しみにしていただければなというふうに思います。